hey youtubers it's Charlie so this video
is gonna be about thor ragnarok villains
they're going full comic-book Firelord
Serdar Fenris wolf you guys have no idea
it's gonna be awesome
so the big news first everybody knew
that Tom Hiddleston was gonna be in the
movie but he like he just joined
Instagram and was like I'm back
and his full Loki makeup now really
early on like around comic-con time
they'd been filming for about five days
they said like the only scenes that
Chris Hemsworth and whole kid film had
been with Loki in Valkyrie this is the
actress that's playing Valkyrie - she
took some nice pictures with Mark
Ruffalo as he was getting ready to leave
she's like you know I can't post
anything really cool stuff but she had a
picture of the rubber sword that she
used while she was filming like when
they're filming they use rubber replicas
of swords so that they won't slice each
other's limbs off whenever they're
hacking at each other so later they just
digitally replaced that with the
relation II looking Valkyrie sword that
you remember from the comics so I've
already done a couple videos about Hulk
and Thor there'll be a road trip aspect
to it where they weave in some Planet
Hulk elements where a lot of the
gladiator Hulk gladiator Thor stuff
comes in but on the flip side of that
Loki is one of many big villains in the
film technically I wouldn't think of him
as the big bat of the film I mean he's a
big villain but the true big bat of the
film is actually being played by Cate
Blanchett and you could also say Fire
Lord Serdar because there was some
concept art teasing Hulk punching Serdar
like you know with him full and frame so
appropriately Serdar will dwarf hulk in
size because he is one of the big
elemental demonic entities of the Thor
comics he rules over this fire realm
he'll they kind of teased it during Thor
the dark world where you see all the
different realms start to align but the
other big one is Fenris wolf who is the
son of Loki in the comics I don't know
how they're gonna weave that into the
movies but it's basically like a wolf
with human-like intelligence that can
change its shape it's very powerful but
owed it like in the comics Odin had
banished it to vanaheim which is a
different realm of Asgard so in the
comic-con teaser it was kind of walking
in the distance along this hill like
it's a giant wolf it's like this 15-foot
tall wolf no idea how they're gonna use
it in the movie but at the thought of
Cate Blanchet hella fire Lords Serdar
giant fire demon versus the Hulk Planet
Hulk and Fenris wolf make your head want
to explode with excitement you need to
thank James Gunn and his trash
forgiving marvel the courage to go full
comic book-like before you know think
about the first Thor movie they actually
included Natalie Portman's character
because they felt like the Thor element
like the fantasy Thor elements were too
high concept for audiences like they
felt like people would just think it was
too silly so they're like okay we're
gonna bring Thor to earth we're gonna
make this more realistic he's gonna have
this human relationship with Jane Foster
people who don't read comics will be
able to relate to the movie so they
didn't really do that many comic book II
things but then you get to throw the
dark world you see some of the
characters from Planet Hulk so it's
getting like a little more comic book II
finally we get to Thor Ragnarok and they
were just like totally not afraid to try
any of the deepest cuts from the Thor
comics think about Hulk versus Fire Lord
Sugar
that is the most comic book thing that I
can think of right now but I guess I
haven't even mentioned Jeff Goldblum's
character the Grandmaster he's one of
the elders of the universe I've talked
about him in previous videos he's not
necessarily the villain of the film he's
kind of like a collector type character
he has no real allegiance the way they
teased him when they announced him for
the movie is that he's kind of like an
inner galactic cosmic pleasure seeker so
he's just really curious he's just
looking for a good time he sees
something interesting going on around
the infinity gems Thanos Loki Loki worms
his way into his good graces as a way to
protect himself because Thanos is coming
for the gems now in part of the concept
art part of the documentary that I've
talked about in the past that they
screened at comic-con it was this really
funny documentary meant to show what
Thor and Hulk were doing during civil
war like oh they weren't here because
they were off just being normal dudes
they found a roommate on Craigslist Thor
was trying to piece together his visions
like they had this childlike drawing up
on the wall like this is actually part
of the real concept art that they were
using at comic-con if you haven't seen
his movie takeout with TD who's
directing Thor Ragnarok actually wrote
and directed this movie called what we
do in the shadows it was kind of like a
mockumentary about a group of vampires
that were flat sharing is actually
pretty funny but that was what the
comic-con teaser they did for Thor
Ragnarok was like they did a version of
that with Thor and Hulk so even though
Thanos is probably gonna parent it like
I said Cate Blanchet I'm still
considering to be the big bat like she's
the person who is probably trying to
take and destroy Asgard but with all
this stuff going out like all these new
characters and comic book things that
they're doing the other really
awesome thing is that because Asgard is
so advanced it's in outer space they're
going to do much more of a space based
story like it's not like Thor's coming
to earth or anything like that which
he's done in the past - Thor films so
this time the Thor Hulk roadtrip will be
a space road trip so we're gonna see a
whole bunch of places they even had a
set that they just built for the Quinjet
that Hulk took off in at the end of age
of Ultron so it seems like that's the
way he gets into outer space is the
Quinn jet which I know a lot of people
were wondering about they're like did
that take him into space are they gonna
do Planet Hulk now well the answer is
kind of yeah but they're mostly doing a
Thor movie there's just a lot of Planet
Hulk stuff happening in it so I wouldn't
be surprised if it winds up looking a
lot more like a gardening's of the
galaxy movie then say like a traditional
Avengers type film because all of those
movies have taken place on earth Thor is
the only other movie besides guardians
of the galaxy that takes place in outer
space let me know what are you guys most
excited for in the film like seeing the
faint like the overstory of fan o's
trying to assemble the Infinity Gauntlet
collect the gems or just watching Kate
Blanchet just wreak havoc on all of
Asgard really even teasing about how
funny it's gonna be I can't wait to see
some of the comedy in it they did a
pretty good job of writing funny
characters in Civil War and Joss
Whedon's always a master of comic book
humor but Tewa Tiki he sounds like he's
gonna have something really really
interesting up his sleeve so I can't
wait to see it but like I said they've
only been filming for a couple weeks now
so I think it's gonna be a while before
we see any footage from it but the other
big news is is that tomorrow there's
gonna be a whole bunch of stuff dropping
for the flash season 3 Supergirl season
2 so be sure to subscribe to get that
there's also a new Star Wars trailer
that's dropping tomorrow night that's
supposed to have Darth Vader in it so we
had new Star Wars we got new flash
season 3 coming tomorrow it's gonna be
crazy
so why you guys wait for that to post
you can click here for my Luke Cage
trailer breakdown and you can click here
to learn more about the spider-man
homecoming villains thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight